when I started public speaking and
losing out on speaking gigs left and
right because I cursed I knew that I was
going to double down on what got me
there which was I'm not going to
overvalue other people's opinions I'm
going to value my opinion about myself
the little voice in your head is called
the insecurity devil the insecurity
devil on your shoulder is saying to you
don't do this because when you fail the
girl you like your brother your mom your
teacher like someone's gonna think you
suck and you believe them and that's the
problem if people really got into a
place of just doing things that they
want to do and not worrying about what
people thought about it everybody would
take risks in their 20s the reason
people are scared of the world is they
actually think getting fired or having
their startup fail or them not being
able to be an influencer because nobody
gave a [ __ ] is a bad thing when I think
it's a great thing this all comes down
to confidence and insecurity the reason
you won't do something is you are too
insecure to do it hi my name is Ruby so
my question
my brain is always grinding always
hustling and that's just who I am that's
where I built myself around but I also
really care about the beginning behind
the work I'm doing and I'm worried that
I'm putting so much effort so in the
irons and the fire that I'll get to the
finish line and realize I'm out of it
was meaningful
but my my question is is how do you make
sure you're putting your effort in
meaningful places and when you're
someone who works super hard when
everything you do how do you maintain a
longevity and not burn out
um
so you don't know if your energy is
going in the right place
and that's exactly how you get to a
place of having no burnout
it's extremely Zen
when you can balance ambition
with patience
and gratitude
for me
I'm just happy I'm playing and whether
it works out or not
is kind of
Irrelevant in some ways truly of course
I'd like to be successful in everything
I do
but
the not judging yourself against your
own ambition
is the superpower
and it's why you never burn out if you
play that game
thank you
and bear with us for a sec because the
sound is still adjusting for a moment
but I think that part of what you know
Ruby and a lot of the other students
here who will hopefully be meeting their
opponents or organizations at some point
in the future as a leader in yourself
how do you convince other people of that
same meaning you don't you don't you
don't commence
you know commencing is a very dangerous
game
what's what happens is you get people on
board
through your actions
I'm such a great communicator one would
think that so much is going for me
because of my communication I would
actually argue that my communication
style is actually a detriment to me up
front because there's a borderline level
of cynicism that has to come along with
the Gift of Gab that people use to
protect themselves and the reason I have
anything meaningful is the truth of my
actions eventually get those that are
closest to see it on board and inspired
to do
and lately you know as you've pivoted
five or six times yourself just in the
last few years where are you finding the
most meaning in your Pursuits
oh disproportionately in the garyvee of
it all like
the garyvee content thing like looking
at these young faces and knowing that
some of them think I'm cool thus giving
me leverage and equity for them to
listen to me so that I can tell them
that kindness and patience and humility
and being a sweet person is actually the
winning formula is massive
you know when I get the feedback from
people that you changed my life because
I realized I didn't have to be a dick
face and I'm not a dick face Gary I'm
not a dick face but I thought you had to
be a dick face to win the game right
like to me that is profound
and you know I think for the people here
who like skew towards being a guidance
counselor or like a camp counselor or
like a head coach or you know this will
make sense to them because I have this
in me when you get your joy from other
people getting Joy from your actions
there's no better Joy
it's just that what's I think a little
bit unique about me if I'm like
analyzing myself as if I'm not myself is
that has come in like spiritual leaders
that's come in like parenting that's
coming guidance counselors and
principles and
it just we haven't heard that from like
gangster ass business people
you know like I think that's what's
probably you know as I analyze it I'm
like why the [ __ ] is this happening I'm
like you know that's right like I can't
think of somebody who like [ __ ] is
crushing out here in that way
that's also spewing
Grandma's [ __ ]
yeah okay
so my name is Levi and I wanted to ask
we are at a point in our lives where we
all feel the bare face similar to what
you talk about a lot in regards to
having the most opportunity to take on
risks and try new things but sometimes
you do the calculations in your head and
even though the risk of failure is so
low for us right now they're still fear
of taking that step a voice telling you
not to what are different ways that we
can conquer that fear also why you curse
so much
I'll answer I'll answer the I'll answer
the easier one
I think somewhere along the line I
realized if I just stay being myself a
lot of good things will happen in a
world where nobody stays themselves
and
I'm a Jersey Boy from the [ __ ]
streets of Edison New Jersey right like
it is this is how I talk it feels this
is how it is in my head no different
than when you wrote that down to ask the
question like that's what was in your
head when I curse it's in my head and
what's interesting is
it used to mainly only come out more in
like public speeches and things of that
nature and then you know like it's just
I just never think brother right I'm
never thinking
right and what I mean by that is I'm
just being natural at all times and so
I don't even know when I'm cursing
genuinely really I really don't it
doesn't even register there's never been
a moment where like I love when people
like don't like it and they're like he's
forcing it I just laugh so much because
I'm like if these people knew how like
there if anything there are times where
I think about not trying to do it but
still can't control it because I'm just
in my flow
as far as your first question
it actually ties to the second question
when I started public speaking and
losing out on speaking gigs left and
right because I cursed
I
knew that I was going to double down on
what got me there which was I'm not
going to overvalue other people's
opinions I'm going to value my opinion
about myself
the little voice in your head
is called the insecurity devil
the insecurity devil on your shoulder is
your word is saying to you don't do this
because when you fail
the girl you like your brother your mom
your teacher like someone's gonna think
you suck
and you believe them
and that's the problem
If people really got into a place of
just doing things that they want to do
and not worrying about what people
thought about it everybody would take
risks in their 20s
You by Nature being in this program
already taking risks that are different
than your contemporaries so you're
already halfway home
but this is still School
even though it's different
and the real world of jobs and companies
and starting your stuff that's the real
jungle
this is just cool right now what you're
doing
but the real jungle is scary because
there is no system it's not subjective
you know teacher Adam can't just say
you're good the world tells you the
truth
and people are scared of the world
that's why we have professional students
and so you know I think um
the reason people are scared of the
world is they actually think getting
fired or having their startup fail or
them not being able to be an influencer
because nobody gave a [ __ ] is a bad
thing when I think it's a great thing
this all comes down to confidence and
insecurity
the reason you won't do something is you
are too insecure to do it
Yeah we actually talk about failure a
lot and I'm curious if you have one that
sticks out from your own past where you
think about it now and you attribute
more of your success to the back
I am one of the all-time worst students
of all time
like actually
like I was you have to understand I was
in the height of college propaganda
when you go to school from 1982 to 1998
you were in The Sweet Spot
of 16 years where I had teacher after
teacher in middle school and high school
tell me that I was going to be a garbage
man because that was the bad thing
and so my failure was macro every
grown-up in my life
besides my parents told me I was going
to fail
my teachers and all my friends parents
I think I'm overly successful
because it wasn't a failure it was a
failure of a generation of growing up
the entire world the thing that
everybody in this room is scared of was
[ __ ] on me every minute on the hour
because your entire self-worth
was about your grades they did not grow
up with that it was a big part of it but
they could have made up that they were
an entrepreneur and people would have
believed them
right I you they could have made up to
their parents and teacher and said I'm
gonna make a million dollars on YouTube
and even though they didn't believe it
there was a one percent that they had to
believe it because it's now true
when I was growing up
you were just [ __ ] out
loud
[Music]
sure you know great
so I is I'm Aaron and I just want to and
just and I noticed that you know you
talk a lot about the importance of
financial independence of dealing with
family members who might not approve of
what we're trying to do for today now
outside of that what are some ways that
you know you learn some ways that you
can work with your family language to
help them get on board with what you're
trying to do if it doesn't fit within
their society their society's
traditional standard per se why do you
want to do that
foreign
that's the answer that's what I was
hoping you would say
um
if your parents are paying for your
existence
they have say
right if your parents are paying for you
to live they have say in what you do
right
and so the question becomes a couple
things
one of the things one of the Frameworks
that most scares me is kids taking their
parents money when they're grown up
to do what they want to do not what
their parents want to do
so I think one of the things to think
about is how do you live more humbly so
you don't take a dollar from them so
that you don't need to sell them on your
mission so that when you accomplish your
mission they'll be proud of you
is that in the cards brother is that
something you can do
yeah
that
because there's a bigger reason I want
you to do that
you're whether you consciously know this
yet or it's sitting in your subconscious
you taking their money
right financially makes you feel like
you can't
there's something incredibly
intoxicating on standing on your own two
feet
and so all that requires is for you to
less Uber less Equinox less Starbucks or
if you do none of those things
three roommates instead of one
yeah
yeah amount of ubereats they could be
saved on this campus yeah like like like
people people don't realize
we're in such a first world country
that the things that they think are
standard are insane luxuries
a man or woman drives to a place to pick
up the food that was made for you and
drops it off for you
you didn't even make we got entitled
where we stopped making our own food now
we don't even go pick it up
so like I think a lot about that so it's
a great question and super important
of course if your parents are paying
they're going to have leverage let's
eliminate their leverage it gives you
Clarity to your focus
and then
when you succeed it tastes 10 times
better
since you guys
effect how you doing
um let's see so I did have another
question however you did bring up and
mention uh float um I kind of want to go
based off that so we discussed flow
within a few of our classes and my kind
of main question is how would you find a
flow if you haven't been able to kind of
discover that yet and then a follow-up
question how do you keep the flow going
um specifically for long periods of time
without getting distracted
by being honest with yourself
you got to really go into a place where
you start really like pushing yourself
emotionally to understand where you're
tricking yourself
where are you tricking yourself
the amount of times I see
kids like yourselves roll up on me and
say Gary I'm gonna buy the Chicago Bulls
you're gonna buy the Jets I'm gonna buy
the Bulls and I could taste it
in their sentence that they know they
can't
the place where it really works is when
you stop peacocking and posturing to
yourself
as a measure to make yourself feel
better
and bigger
and actually you're just comfortable
with what you are you get really into
your state this is what's so great about
my life you're a failure you're going to
be a garbage man and I was just like I
just like selling stuff you know and I
don't care that everybody thinks that
I'm not a lawyer or a doctor
or an executive like I'm happy and if
that makes you know I was a pig and [ __ ]
at 27 making 70 000 a year pumped
working every day at a liquor store
helping my family like
flows easy Once you stop lying to
yourself and what and once you stop
trying to impress others with the [ __ ]
that comes out of your mouth
right and then back to your point I've
seen a lot of people that use flow to
get there but then they're in new places
and then they stop they were confident
enough to get it here but now that
they're in like this upper middle class
of society that's when they stop start
posturing because they're like they
thought they were good but this person
they just met has a yacht and they're
like yo they feel lesser than and they
can't keep their flow because they stop
doing the thing that got them there the
thing that got them there was not giving
a [ __ ] but now that they got this new
place
like something changed because like
because they didn't even realize [ __ ]
got that crazy up here and they actually
do feel insecure
uh Nate
uh hey Gary I'm Nate um I'm really
curious about the value of new
experiences and trying new things I want
something new that you could try in your
career that you hadn't done before and
ended up having an impact on your
trajectory that you are expecting
uh I started to deploy Candor one-on-one
not just in settings like this
Candor was very hard for me team I
really struggled with confrontation and
being the deliverer of bad news
and so it completely changed it
trajectory of my career I started
realizing everything that wasn't working
for me professionally and personally was
based on my ability to be candorous
and so about three four years ago I
started getting better at it I still
struggle with it I'm still maybe a
D plus C minus C I'm on the way but I
was in F land and from F to C is like
[ __ ] been remarkable and the impact
is I'm well on my way for the personal
and professional
you know accomplishments that I want for
myself and so I've gone in the macro
what it's meant is I've gone from a to a
plus
because that's where I was getting
[ __ ] up everything was so good anyway
kind of sorta that it was like hidden
that this was like when you're living in
a life and I am
uh it was hard to see that there was
something to get to a plus and I had to
go through some painful things
professionally and personally to get
there
so for
eign
siblings relationship parents friends
and then you know like life like I'm
very I don't need much so it was very
easy for me to eat a ton of [ __ ] and
build subconscious resentment
but I was so happy overall I never
needed to kind of call that card
but then in certain scenarios it became
not sustainable it really hurt me with
in professionally and firing people got
very dirty because I wasn't giving
enough feedback and then they'd be
surprised and I was like resentful at
them because they sucked the whole time
I was like how do you not know this and
like it became dirty but that was on me
I had to be accountable
well Shameless plug maybe it's going to
be working Advantage Sports one day so
he'll reach out later yeah I love it
you know we represent do you know Nate
do you know do you know that we
represent O'Neill Cruz
I do not know that no that's there you
go
all right hello Gary Uncle Johnny
um so we're
to all of us we're the stars of our own
movie and a lot of Our Generation
especially have grown up with dreams of
becoming Super Famous and super
well-loved and super well known and
you're one of the people that that's
actually happened to and it's like a
result of your entrepreneurship and so
now that you've reached this place that
people dream about
what sort of value and meaning do you
feel that celebrity brings to your life
versus if you have remained a successful
an unknown entrepreneur
um
it's brought only the opportunity to
positively impact more people
everything else is a drag
like yeah like that's not fair I love
people so much at like such a weird
level the fact that like
it's kind of weird like I'm thinking
through at the airport
pre-garyvee I would just like roll up on
people and just start talking to them
I'm weird like that in the best way like
I wouldn't weird people out I would find
you know I'm good I have good intuition
I could see where I could get into a
combo
postgaryvee it all comes to me so that's
good
in a way right
but like
I don't like
when people treat me different
because they know that there's something
going on with me because I'm
uncomfortable with it and I don't need
it
like I don't need a free appetizer
like I don't need to cut a line
you know
like so
you know the good thing is I can make
people happy
a great I'll give you a cliche thing
that people usually say the other way I
go the other way the one of the best
things is I take a million selfies
why because I know when that person
leaves they're pumped and I can talk I
can feel what I would feel like
20 years ago if I had the opportunity to
do that with Macho Man Randy Savage
right like so I understand what that is
um
but you have to understand this will
make sense to you I
I was 30 years old before I made a video
think about that
I was 30 before I made my first piece of
content
so it wasn't like something I wanted or
aspired to I didn't move to LA like it's
not
the fame
is um
fine it's good for business development
I like that leads to opportunities
but by far the best part is
some of you will actually listen to some
of the things I'm saying
and that will be good for you and that
feels good for me
my name is
um and I need to ask a lot of questions
every single day
um but what's something that you don't
normally share with people something
that might be unusual to your current
audience
that's a good question I think um you
know most of the stuff I don't share is
like personal family stuff you know I
think um
um and I like to keep that private
because it's other people's business
it's not mine to share when it's you
know
as far as everything else like I'm
really open book life like I really try
to share with y'all I think the part
that probably would confuse most of you
is like truly how Zen I really am
like it is really that chill I'm high
energy and I'm go go go but like
I'm really trying to figure out how to
get people less anxious you know
and so
I don't think people would know how they
I don't think they could believe how
busy I actually am
I think that stands out like I don't
think people really realize that I have
43 meetings a day
[Music]
like I don't think they realize how
hectic it is and I don't think they
realize how easy it is
if you go to the place we've been
talking about emotionally
[Music]